I want to talk about Tucker Carlson for
a minute because he was big in the news
this week I don't know if you saw this
but he blew the lid on what happened on
January 6 2021 for real
uh no really this was his big thing
Trump tweeted about it uh you know the
unpleasantness at the Capitol that
happened that day well according to Taco
you heard it wrong the unpleasantness
well it was actually not unpleasant is
what Trucker's thesis is and he showed
footage of people and it's real footage
from that day you can't deny that but
there's a lot of footage from that day
and it's people well I'm not going to
show that footage but I'm going to read
exactly what he said this is what Tucker
said and he showed his footage from
January 6. I'm going to read his words
under the footage we chose from January
6.
I want to stress to you
both those footages are real and these
are exactly the words he said he said
we're going to begin tonight with
footage that shows you exactly what was
happening inside the capitol the footage
does not show an insurrection
or a riot in progress instead it shows
police escorting protesters through the
building
they were peaceful they were orderly and
meek
these were not insurrectionists they
were sightseers
protesters queue up in neat little lines
they give each other tours outside the
speaker's office they take cheerful
selfies and they smile
they're not destroying the capital
[Applause]
they obviously Revere the capital
okay so everyone is uh
everyone is coming down on trucker
Carlson I just want to defend him and
say I think this is an exciting new way
to teach history
you teach the things that didn't happen
if the things that didn't go on if
you're a history buff like I am you'll
want to see more of this so we are
partnering with Fox News to bring you a
set of gold coins
the Carlson collection of non-evance
and here are some of the ones you'll get
you'll get JFK's uneventful flight to
Dallas
thank you
uh the Sears Tower on 9 11.
Kanye on his on his meds
Cyrus is from the Wuhan lab
you'll get Bob Weinstein
[Music]
you'll get Jeffrey Dahmer eats his salad
you'll get Hitler petting his dog
and the time George Santos said
something true